my name is Mark ma RC last name Brenner
with one and bre any our project is
called say it ain't so low my name is
Jeff Gotham an actor but marks good
friends here to celebrate are you in the
project I'm in the project okay so how
is it working as friends you have
boundaries in terms of their no
boundaries and no badness is the best
part yes we didn't wear shirts on the
set hey Barry comes that was great I
mean it was just here's the script I
know sensibilities he now knocked out of
the park in what's the film about the
film was about a father and son in this
world where every film as a Hollywood
remake they find out their favorite
movie star wars is about to be remade
and they enlist the help of their
celebrity friends to stop this movie
from being remade okay and is it based
on your own relationship with your
father did you have a close relationship
or he took to the film and yet my dad
took me to the movies all the time but
it was more so I kind of paired it with
the whole father-son relationship of
Star Wars as well in a way and just
we've got a I love movies and i'm so
tired of all these movies being remade
and so I thought what happens if they
made Star Wars people might go okay was
there a point where you almost give up
on the project or it got so frustrated
no I mean there's one of those things
where everything came together
real nice
smart person beard by getting a lot of
people on board from the start and as
you know a couple people added on their
names his brother is a great actor also
Josh Brener this is the project and we
can't do tonight but yes and once I
think people came on board it's sort of
decision from there but yeah it's a fun
like tongue-in-cheek scrimped on like
Hollywood remakes and the over the
overkill oh that's right and we got a
whole bunch of amazing cameos
Christopher Lloyd Jason Alexander Malin
Akerman emmanuelle chriqui Kunal Nayyar
whole bunch of list great fantastic
people have helped us out with this film
now personal question a little bit maybe
too personal but it was there ever a
point that you want to give up on active
there's always I mean you think about
that on a lot of days but it depends on
what you're doing you know keeping busy
in the other day to day life so you know
we're just talking about that today like
keeping keeping strolling on with other
projects and
acton can't be your entire life and if
it if it's screen roles and goes that
way fine but until there you stay busy
and enjoy the day to day you can't just
can't be down and last question is that
your mantra that you can't be down about
it what do you tell me to kind of keep
yourself going because this is an uneasy
business and some days are better than
others some days people return phone
calls in my mantra is patience and and
you have to do it on your own that's my
main be alright I believe you can you
know have your scripts that you're
trying to get the studios to make but in
the meantime you have to have your own
project that you can physically make
yourself whether be a five hundred
dollar budgets all the way up to a five
hundred thousand dollar budget and
beyond just get to keep busy and drink
make your own things
it's great yeah totally agree like you
can't can't be come down on one certain
aspect you you kind of stay focused and
if something else comes up fine yeah
marks marks been tried a couple things
here and there for a while and he knows
what he's doing so some days you still
friends okay so far thank you see what
happens after you know how the crowd
reacts